si vous nous rejoignez en ce moment même
que vous rentrez chez vous après votre
travail il est 17h30 je vous rappelle qu
aux alentours de 14h30 un peu avant 15
heures si je me souviens bien maintenant
un peu avant 15 heures un premier avion
s'est encastrée dans l'une des tours du
world trade center c'est à dire le coeur
économique de la ville de new york
depuis les événements se sont
malheureusement enchaîné pour se
terminer en ce moment même en
catastrophe nationale pour l'ensemble
des états unis vous propose si vous nous
rejoignez à l'instant même de revoir
l'ensemble des événements
chronologiquement dans l'après-midi avec
thierry curtet l'image est incroyable
derrière la tour à gauche alors qu à
8h50 à premier avion a percuté l'une des
deux tours du world trade center
18 minutes plus tard un deuxième avion
un avion de ligne
un boeing 737 united airlines vient
percuter la deuxième tour du wall trade
center d'après les premières
constatations du fbi haye
les deux appareils n'ont pas dévié d'un
seul maître dans leur trajectoire visant
délibérément les deux tours
et puis un peu plus d'une heure plus
tard un troisième avion kamikaze vient
s'écraser sur le quartier général de
l'armée la plus puissante du monde
le pentagone il semble qu'une voiture
piégée est aussi explosé aux abords ou
dans le siège du pentagone pour
l'instant on ne sait pas très bien
la première des deux tours va basculer
sur sa base puis s'effondrer chacun des
deux bâtiments pèse plus de 300 mille
tonnes et la deuxième tour ne va pas
résister plus longtemps
elle s'écroule sur elle-même les dégâts
aux alentours sont forcément immense
dans une ville à la densité urbaine de
new york
8h50 c'est l'ouverture des bureaux à
deux pas de mon street quarante mille
personnes travaillent dans ce
prestigieux centre commercial on ne sait
pas combien d'employés ont pu être
évacués
avant la 12e curieux vous au centre
commercial avait déjà été victime de
l'attentât islamiste 193 pour l'instant
aucun bilan sérieux n'a été publié mais
le maire de new york parle d'un nombre
terrifiant de victimes
le quartier a été entièrement évacué en
apprend également qu'un boeing 747
assurant la liaison chicago new york
vient de s'écraser dans l'ouest de la
pennsylvanie
l'aviation civile américaine a bloqué
tous les aéroports dans tout le pays
collant tous les avions commerciaux au
sol toutes les bourses américaines ont
été fermées
le pays est paralysé